[Music]
California hi Rene welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi Dave good to be here good
to have you how can I help
uh I just started listening to your
podcast and I'm on baby step number one
and so in what I'm doing in parallel is
I just have a question as far as paying
off debt I have two cards that I opened
with no interest rate for a number of
months into next year and then I have
the traditional cards with interest and
one with a very high balance so should I
your your program says pay the smallest
balance off first
yes ma'am should I pay the ones off with
interest now no and then go after it
smaller ones without interest nope nope
you might know why let me tell you why
okay cuz why matters okay it's on I
actually am a math nerd beyond belief
and so if you were a hardcore math nerd
technically mathematically you would
list your debts highest interest rate to
smallest interest rate first and if you
paid the exact same amount on that
program that you paid on the get out of
debt plan that we use smallest balance
the largest balance you would get out of
debt faster because you're not paying as
much interest if you pay the higher
interest off first
and that makes mathematical sense but
what we have discovered is is that this
is not a math problem if you were doing
math you wouldn't have credit card debt
term this is not a math issue this is a
overspending disorganised not on a
budget time to grow up and not buy stuff
I can't afford unless I have the cash
problem yes I've come to have had my
come to Jesus oh man yeah I mean that's
what I had to and it's the same thing
and so what I've discovered over thirty
years of teaching this is
that um if I can get you to believe
because you're having successes that
you're going to win you will work even
that much harder to keep at it than just
the intellectual discussion of interest
rates mm-hmm because it's not an
intellectual problem it's not a problem
of intellect you have the sufficient
intellect to have not done this but you
bought stuff you couldn't afford but I
don't a credit card I did that to all
kinds of stuff I mean how everybody's
done that just about at times so no
shame um not shaming you for that I'm
just saying that so the point is you
don't fix a behavior problem with a math
solution you fix a behavior problem with
a behavior solution and paying off the
smallest one even though it is illogical
will cause you to have more success
because you'll get fired up because
you're having some success it's kind of
like a lot of people go on a diet and if
you let's say you had a diet program one
diet program that was intellectually
correct an extra snot and exercise
program and it was intellectually
correct but you weren't gonna lose any
weight at all for three months and then
in ten days you'd lose thirty pounds no
one would do it because they couldn't
stay with it three months with no
positive feedback but if you go on a
diet that does not work as well and an
exercise program it doesn't work as well
but you lose three pounds the first week
and then two pounds the next week and
then a pound or two the next week you'll
stay with it because you can see the
progress you can feel the progress
you're not having to delay the results
way out there and so that's the reason
that that snowball works and we list our
death smallest to largest because when
you pay off the little one you're like
hey that's cool and then you pay off the
next one's like oh that's very
interesting and then you power for
another one y'all hey this is kind of
working this guy ain't crazy as he
sounds you know and then you pound
another one you like Wow and then you
get an out power for another one you
like I'm never gonna eat again let's do
this my game on you know and the more
you win the more fired up you get and
the deeper you sacrifice and the you
know the less you worry about what other
people think or say
and the more you lean in and push this
through and so that's the reasoning
behind it okay one more question so one
of the credit cards I told you about
weight interest has super high payments
and it's really hard to make sometimes
because I have a mortgage - what is the
net still applied
still applies payments not relevant even
we're gonna pay off the launch - so how
many credit card debts have you got I
have four okay and so two of them are
two of them are higher interest rates
and when I've got a high payment so what
are the balances on the two big ones um
the two big ones is 15,000 the highest
balance is 15 and the second one is
really nominal I just need to pay it off
like 500 bucks those are the cards with
interest and the one if $14,000 $15,000
a month in payment yeah
well that's great news because even if
you don't do anything so just pay the
payment you're gonna get that thing paid
off pretty quick because you're paying
large principal payments if you're
paying $2,000 a month on I mean what's
the interest rate on it 25 no it's 16
yeah okay and so you're gonna pay you'd
pay that off pretty quickly regardless
if you kept paying $2,000 a month
there's two thousand and fifty thousand
and two fifteen thousand is seven and a
half months plus interest so eight or
nine months of $2,000 and that one's
calling anyway mm-hmm even with the
interest so you're gonna get there so
what's your household income got 109
good that's good news okay and how much
other debt have you got other than these
credit cards that's it
okay that's great she got a 14 or 15 a
500 and what's the fourth one the other
two are 45 and 17 and those are I don't
it's like same as cash kind of thing no
interest rate twenty five hundred or
thousand one hundred two hundred and
seventy
hundred oh good okay yeah to be paid off
until next April is there five cards or
four cards four total including the $500
one mm-hmm okay all right so you have
one great big one yeah that's the one
that kicks those kicks my butt every my
hot yeah okay cool
but here's the thing you knock off 500
and then and then 1,700 and then 4,500
you're gonna you're gonna feel like you
got rid of all the mosquitoes that are
flying around and now you just got to
shoot the elephant okay
like you're stomping out the little
stuff so you can focus on the big one
okay and then you'll be able to reach
over and punch him in the head and plus
you get on a written budget you make
enough money to do this pretty quick
I know and I and I started listening to
your podcast so now I'm gonna I don't
know I need to get your book you need to
download the every dollar budget and
start using it and it's free it's a free
budget seven million people are using
the online budget and it's an app and
it'll work on your phone and everything
and it takes about ten minutes set your
budget up and you give every dollar a
name before the month begins and you get
traction and you start to move and hold
on I'll give you a copy the Total Money
Makeover book that'll be our Christmas
present between you and me as a new
listener so we'll get you going here
kiddo hey thank you for the call